- Time's almost up on this
hour now, but not quite yet.
We have one more inspiring story to share,
this is What I'm Liking.
So six years ago, Leo moved
to Illinois from the Philippines.
He was nervous about the
move, but he settled in
with a job as a janitor at
a local elementary school.
The students and faculty
welcomed Leo with open arms.
In fact, they call him Mr. Leo.
Last year, he applied for
citizenship and on January 24th,
he was sworn in as a US citizen.
(audience applauds)
That's right.
The next day, this is
how students greeted him.
- [Students] Yay!
Leo! Leo! Leo! Leo!
Leo! Leo! Leo! Leo! Leo!
- It's so sweet.
(audience applauds)
We have Mr. Leo on the line,
so congratulations, Mr. Leo!
(audience applauds)
- Hi Kelly.
- Hi, so I have to ask, what was it like
walking to the hallway and
everybody cheering for you?
- Oh, it was so surprising.
I was so surprised when I got in the door
and right from there, I already was crying
because of the kids shouting, "Leo! Leo!"
and it was so heartwarming
and overwhelming for me.
- Oh my God, and it's also...
This is also meaningful for
you for other reasons, right?
- Because coming into the United States
through a petition of my
son, who is a nurse here.
He wanted me to help with
the household, with the kids.
So I drove the kids, I
take good care of the kids.
Then it so happened that
there was a job opening
at Charles Street elementary school
so I applied for it as a
custodian and until now I'm here.
I love my job, I love
the kids and the staff
for their overwhelming support for me
as I do my job for them.
- Aw, I love it.
Thank you so much Mr. Leo,
for sharing this with us.
It's such a great story.
I'm so proud of you, I'm happy for you.
This is awesome for your family.
I love that you're able to
be there for your grandkids.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
All right, well that's not all, Mr. Leo.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show,
they want to honor ultimate overachievers
just like you, sir.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars, how's that sound?
(audience applauds)
- Oh thank you, thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Yeah, have a
good time with that money!